now we're going to do something that's
rather rude which is we're going to talk
to you while you're trying to eat and I
apologize for that but this is the only
place we could fit something in we
wanted to have a chance to give you a
little bit more background about the
idea of the gigapan community and so I'm
going to make this brief because your
your workshops start again at 130 and
i'll try and make it informal and i'll
attempt to leave room for questions and
we'll see if i can fit all of those
bills some of you by the way are outside
with Jeff Warren right now who is flying
his gigapan flying machine which is
pretty awesome so I think they're having
fun out there and maybe they're having
more fun than we're having but we eating
and that's something first of all I want
to tell you about the home laboratory of
the work that you've been seeing here
and that's the create lab it's an
unusual laboratory I'm situated in
robotics in the robotics Institute but
the create lab has more than two dozen
researchers from a variety of fields and
that works because robotics can be
interpreted so dramatically in diverse
ways by different people so we have
people who understand curriculum we have
psychology experts people who understand
learning sciences we have mechanical
engineers of course electrical engineers
of course and computer scientists of
course but then we have people who work
on firmware and they're really their
world is designing small circuit systems
and then making them become reality the
fundamental goal that the create lab has
in all of its projects is to pick a
community of practice and then invent
the technology for that community that
empowers them and the general litmus
test we use is can we invent a
technology that we can produce in
reasonable quantities right 202,000
20,000 deploy into a community do
training and will the community in turn
feel empowered to influence the future
of their community and the future of
technology and its use in their
community so we evaluate and study that
after effects and of course we have to
study the process of innovation to
create the technology that will find use
in that community we have specific
projects for four-year-olds in daycare
centers we have particular projects for
middle school girls in terms of
technology literacy and empowerment we
have a number of programs for high
schoolers we have programs for garages
independent garages that service cars we
have programs of course for
photographers and science
who are to use gigapixel imagery so this
is one of a number of projects we have
about 12 hot projects right now in the
lab and so in fact the people that you
know that you've met that are from the
create lab all juggle and so for
instance Randy sergeant or anybody else
that you've met oh hi Ron or others all
of them were involved in a number of
projects and so that's something I think
is impressive these people are juggling
between many many projects all of which
have community outreach components and
you're seeing them with one hat on but
have a discussion with them about their
other projects and I think you'll enjoy
learning more about their other projects
having said that about the create lab
David course when I did a fantastic job
this morning of giving you a good
introduction to why we started the
global connection project I his story
was completely accurate I wanted to add
one bit of information to it that's fun
to think about when we were playing with
keyhole which Alan Eustace mentioned in
his in the second keynote as well the
question that we had asked following the
Mars rover pictures and this is the
question that really randy asked first
was how can we get people on earth to
better understand one another to cross
boundaries if you will and to better
understand the earth itself and that's a
really deep and difficult question to
answer and many people try and work on
that problem in many ways especially
scientists like you one of the
interesting answers it was that Randy
purchased a copy of keyhole which was
this program that allowed you to look at
the earth rotated about zoom in and see
it in greater detail and as we played
with that we realized that the process
the experience of zooming in and
revealing detail on the earth
geographically was much like the process
of visualization that astronauts had
from the space for the while they were
looking at the earth and this took us to
a quote that Randy identified and both
of us enjoyed that Yuri Gagarin said a
very long time ago which was that
circling the Earth I marvel at the
beauty the planets and then he kind of
makes this mission statement right
people of the world let's safeguard
enhance this beauty let's not destroy it
that's exciting because in fact as you
read reports by astronauts going back to
the ground over and over again you see
in astronauts a sense of vision about
the earth that has changed after their
orbits and so in fact we went through
one kind of put in not put enough
tongue-in-cheek that's the thing
tongue-in-cheek I knew it was inevitable
something in the mouth we went through
this tongue-in-cheek process of saying
well what if we just took the US
Congress and got them all in orbit once
because maybe then they make better
decisions right if they would go through
this kind of transformation
philosophically the problem is we also
calculate the amount of carbon dioxide
that would be released sending all of
the Congress in space and even if they
do well we'd be in big trouble so we
can't say the mall in space so to us
keyhole was in a way a second best step
what if using visualization technologies
we can create that sense of empowerment
the problem was that's not empowerment
seeing the Earth from above is great but
what you really want to do is learn
about the earth you want deep narrative
embedded within that sense of image so
if you think in the kind of Aristotelian
wonder sense that that image gives us
wonder it makes us want to learn that's
great that's a sponge now we're a sponge
now we need something to to pull and so
you have to have information that's so
compelling that somebody can then pull
that information and digest it and learn
something now that they're excited and
they have wonder so wonder is the
catalyst but we need the thing that
comes after the catalyst we need the
essential chemicals that can react and
cause people to behave better so global
connection indeed started with this
whole conception of using the power of
imagery to cross borders and to cross
people's understanding of the earth
itself that's how we started and it was
actually my wife Marty who made this
point early in this that well if you're
trying to get the best images on earth
to layer upon that globe so that you can
see more deeply the meaning of the earth
itself National Geographic is a great
example of the best images in the world
right maybe time life maybe national so
we went with National Geographic and we
pitched it to them and they actually
wrote back to us and Anna cold email we
sent an email to the head of online at
National Geographic and incredibly she
wrote back a month and a half later it's
a koala and Google wrote back and we got
them all in the same room so that was
indeed how it started and one of the
first projects we did was to create a
layer on Google Earth but it required
massive detective work what we had to do
was get all sorts of images and articles
from National Geographic then we had to
hire an army of undergraduates here to
go and call photographers do research
figure out exactly what the GPS cord
where where those pictures were taken
these were not geotagged so we had to
come up with the geo tags and I'll give
you one example there was a picture
taken through a subway window we had to
figure out we knew what city was and we
had to figure out the half of the street
sign you could see outside what streets
could it possibly be that are visible
through a subway window at all the
subway stops in that city and we figured
it out and he attacked it that way so we
had investigators here essentially doing
investigation to answer those questions
and geotagging these images and then we
create this layer the National
Geographic layer on Google Earth and we
were very proud of that that was great
because it gave us great information
reveals about the earth you can zoom in
on the earth and get a sense of the fact
that geographic political boundaries
don't matter but when you zoom in you
can also read stories you can read
articles about cultures about endangered
species and you can see pictures so to
us that was a great step forward and we
were very excited about that the reason
the GigaPan was disruptive in a
different way is because the issue with
this kind of imagery and for that matter
the issue with Street View the issue
with anything that is provided
professionally is the professionals are
doing the taking and to us it was
fundamentally important to empower
individuals to do the taking to
democratize if you will the creation of
that very content that the catalyst is
supposed to trigger so we want the
content to be crowd-sourced to do that
you go down the line and realize okay
then we need hardware we need software
to create stitching just as our friends
at Auto pano do and you need a place to
put the images as well as an ability to
create at that place a sense of
community enough community to have
interaction and teaching and learning
and conversation so that's what really
led to the thing that we have now this
is just for fun we have a Mars yard a
lunar yard at NASA Ames and we tested
one of the very early gigapan systems
there this is kind of fun because you
can see the stepper motor on the right
and the way we talk to the camera was
there was little LED in front of it
talking into it led into its infrared
port now in starting to use that robot
and remember the create lab is about
taking technology and directly applying
the technology to some
social good with some community of
practice right so we're not
technologists that want to just throw it
out there and see where the winds take
it okay given that sense we right away
wanted to do educational work with it
and so we started partnering with
various organizations educationally to
try and see how will educate as use this
technology I'm going to tell you a few
stories about that because it starts to
set you up for what we stirred discovery
was exciting this is an example of a
mural here in Wilkinsburg which with J's
methods i could take much better but
it's a mural that is interesting because
it's filled with meaning for the
african-american community that lives
where it was taken and that is indeed a
very low income neighborhood in
Pittsburgh what did the YMCA and YWCA do
with this they sent students out to take
these images the images were taken by
the students then we had a workshop
where the students showed these as a
sort of gallery show on computers to
their parents but then the parents sat
down next to the students and then we
asked the students and parents together
to snapshot and annotate the images and
then the almost heartbreaking thing
happened or heartwarming thing depending
on how you look at it the parents sat
down with the students they'd point and
gesture the students would zoom in they
point at a face talk about what that
basement to them and why it was in the
mural and how when they were a teenager
that was critical to the thoughts that
they had about emancipation about
equality about equity and the student
would be writing together with their
parents prose about those pictures so
you had parents and children together
creating a moment of remembrance about
the parents life about the critical
aspects that made such a difference to
their identity and to the transformation
of their identity and persona over time
and then we talked to the parents about
this experience and they hadn't had that
experience with their kids they could go
there right they could go to that place
and talk about it they go shopping right
next door every day you walk by the
mural every day but they don't stop go
there and talk about the pictures the
fact that here they were faced with the
situation where they can annotate it and
create written documentation on the site
that anybody in the world can view gave
them a sense of leverage of power
because they have a loudspeaker
and that filled them with the import of
saying the right thing so together they
would design and form and mold just what
to say so that they're expressing
themselves well because it's not a
transient comment even to your child
which actually is very important
transient comment but if the comment
that you're etching into a stone and
that's don't happen to be a website so
there's something about that interplay
between history cultural heritage and
image and intergenerational dialogue
that I found absolutely compelling and
the gigapan site in essence is a way to
try and bind those together and create
learning sharing internationally through
that so that's one way of thinking about
it now internationally is right we're in
I don't even know how many countries
right now more than 14 countries that's
for sure so in more than 14 countries
either with National Geographic or with
UNESCO into international bureau of
Education we've been doing programming
where we go in and give children yoga
pants just like we give them to
scientists like you and then we give the
same depends the children in the United
States Trinidad Tobago Indonesia Brazil
so a toast and apricots and in each of
these situations the children then come
up with dematic contributions let's take
pictures of something in our country and
share it with children in another
country and then we go in snapshot and
explore each other's images and through
the snapshots we have a conversation so
you end up with a cross-cultural
conversation that's spatially referenced
sometimes it's scary the results this
was Ted see machine II memorial in
Soweto we're essentially the uprising
against applicants as the first spoken
language came it was an incredibly
important place in the middle of Soweto
and the children we took their who were
middle school students at la vella high
school at lavella middle school and in
Soweto they didn't know what it was
their school was walking distance from
this but apartheid is already so far in
the past in South Africa as absurd as
this may seem to those of us were older
than 10 that in fact they were aware of
the historical import of this place and
the gentleman the young boy who was
killed here so they didn't know that
story and it was through the research
they had to do to annotate this picture
for the students who were in South
Fayette high school here in Pittsburgh
did they learn that story so they only
learned it when they had the empowerment
of having that loudspeaker put on their
lips knowing that they're going to tell
that story to the children here in South
Fayette and then they put the story in
fact then they learned the story and
they told the story so again there's
something exciting about the sociology
of the internet bridging culture where
when you spatially locate that
information you can trigger real
learning locally where the real learning
is in fact much more important perhaps
than the actual annotation itself
because you're changing the local life
here's another example children in
pittsburgh and in salado took pictures
of graffiti and trash and pollution in
each city in urban areas in dense urban
areas and then had an entire series of
conversations about what is it that
causes humans to pollute their world why
do we enter a regime where we think it's
all right to do that when we're walking
down the street every day and yet I can
throw my gum wrapper down on the street
so there's a took pictures of urban
areas and then snap shotted things like
gum wrappers in trash and litter and
then what was interesting is they
discovered that they could take pictures
that were impossible to locate they
started taking pictures gigapan of each
place that you can't tell whether it's a
gigapan of South Africa or America it's
an urban area that can exist easily in
either place and it's a kind of
littering that you're seeing they can
exist easily in either place you're
bridging culture and you're showing
people a kind of empathy for a problem
but also a kind of relative cultural
empathy for what can exist across
culture and that's really meet these are
the stories that are fun to tell this is
an interesting picture because one of
the things that I'm very convinced of is
that the print medium of Giga pam's is
very very large vehicles is incredibly
important and it's important for two or
three I think critical reasons and
that's why you have some prints here and
I have a big gallery show in the gallery
of the coding use of Natural History one
reason that that borders around
community is conviviality it is an
important aspect of us as human social
creatures that we like to have convivial
ever-present instantaneous shared
experience when I can stand next to you
shoulder to shoulder with you and look
at that physical print on the wall I
have a shared experience with you
and I have new kinds of common grounds
that I share with you the distribution
on the internet completely fails to
afford us that kind of physical
conviviality and so the experience we
get by exploring and uncovering in the
internet is fantastic and the Obama
pictures an excellent example of that it
doesn't look so good as a print we have
it in our lab but it looks fabulous when
you zoom in and out it's a dynamic and
it's a dynamic that has power there yet
for a picture like the grass there it
looks beautiful as a print and you can
have a conversation with somebody about
that pit right next to it in that
conversation to a quite compelling
there's nothing about that in dynamic
form that I find more pleasing than the
print so there is something interesting
to be said for the print out there is a
second reason though that print outs are
particularly powerful and this goes
right back down to empowerment again
when you create a gallery show and you
print a 20 gigapan gallery show in
soweto where half the prints are prints
of reproductions of your japan's taken
by children in the united states and
half the prints are prints taken of gig
depends taken by children in south
africa what you've created is an art
space because of the border that we seem
to be d sharpening between art and
technology and in creating an art space
you empower the children to feel like
they're artists like their communicators
and again that they have a voice that
people care about what they think and
say so what happens is here we have an
art opening the children are there but
we have buses that bring in their
friends and their families in their
extended families from Soweto so they
come into an art space where it's a
gallery opening but the gallery the
respected gallery honored guests are
children and that puts children in a
different place because they start to
think about the idea that they can use
technology to have a place of respective
society where they can make a statement
and have their statement heard
metaphorically through an image or
directly through narrative so that
gallery showing I think is incredibly
important and as you reach out and work
in educational settings I can't
encourage you enough to consider having
gallery shows whether it's for collegial
scientists or whether it's for a local
high school with which you're going to
do some studies of biodiversity in a
backyard
now just a few fun things to point out
about the gigapan site and other ways in
which the GigaPan community is using
those very gay pants it's always fun to
be an adventure capital pitch and hear
people tell you how fast they're growing
so one of the fun measures of growth has
to do with Tara pixels uploaded how many
Tara pixels do we have and Paul heck
Bert has a poster presentation authored
by many people in create lab and i'm
steve i'm borrowing these from him i
said steel it's actually borrowing
because i asked his permission i guess
that makes it borrowing right yeah i
think so and this is an interesting
graph because as you can see it's not
linear and in fact it's ever steeper and
recently has gone to a whole new mode of
steepness so that's kind of fun right
it's exciting to imagine that the
gradual evolution of technology itself
right the greater and greater
accessibility of hardware from companies
like you get parent systems and auto
pano and several other companies in fact
software the stitchers that are
available for many companies and the
fact that cameras themselves are
becoming easier to use and higher in
megapixel count all of those are
basically joining forces to give us
increasing stiffnesses in terms of Terra
pixels uploaded to gigapan work of
course it also means the site's getting
more popular that the idea doesn't have
a kind of natural growth limitation
based on professional photographers it's
much broader than professional
photographers this is another way to
look at a scatterplot this is really
cool when you consider that the left
axis the vertical axis is on a log scale
so on a log scale the thing is going
superlinear which is really cool that
means it's growing very very quickly
this gives me heartburn because we have
to buy hard drives I used to think hard
drives will get cheaper and bigger
faster than gigapan woodrow and i was
wrong they're not getting cheaper fast
enough so that's a problem it's a good
problem it's a good problem now use of
Giga pans on Giggy pans website is well
documented those papers about it and
many of you have described how you've
used it some of you has also described
how you've taken that very imagery and
served it either directly from your own
servers or served it into your own
website from gigapan site this idea of
embedding or syndication where you take
the data you upload to a server so that
you know it exists but then you create
your own reformulation of how to tell a
narrative that is strong with that
information that's really important and
that's something that we really want
people to appreciate and to invent
around so in the spirit of that I want
to describe a couple of projects that go
in that direction there's one really
exciting project which really relied on
the recognition that we have several
GigaPan errs who have become quite good
at GigaPan nekid annotation at
collecting and understanding a pants at
the same time we have a great body of
Giga pans on the site there's 60,000 gb
pans there you can't serve that so let's
have guessed curatorial episodes and the
only our own who's there is the director
of outreach for the create lab do all
start a project to create something
called gigapan magazine and I want you
to be aware of it you can go to gigapan
magazine org and in fact what happens on
this is you have curated yes curated
guest-edited issues where some pho
editor has come up with a project theme
and then for that thesis they have found
a series of Giga pans contacted authors
and experts have the authors and experts
go into those Gigot pans and annotate
them with great detail so there's a
great deal of information in a snapshot
description to read about each of the
snapshots and an overall description of
the image and then collected all of that
into one place and I just want to show
you a couple for fun and for a good
reason I believe science and society
which is the second volume fifth issue
so we've been doing this for a couple of
years now I believe this was a guest
edited by Molly mailing is that true I
think so she here she was here yesterday
but anyway molly is the guest editor for
this entire issue which is pretty
exciting she's a fine fellow and the
issue is about science and society and
if you were to go and go to the wrong
slide then you'll see something
different I'm supposed to go to the
slide now
yeah so if i go two stories then i can
see that in fact there's a number of
stories here to tell about birds and
bees ice breakers foreign fish stopping
by woods coping with water and i can
pick one of these whichever one i like
and go and learn about it and it's doing
nothing other than linking me to the
GigaPan site so this is not even a
sophisticated use of embedding
technology right but that's not what
matters what matters is that you had
experts go in and create fantastic
information carbohydrates versus protein
nectar which is converted into honey
once it's brought back to the hive is
the honey bees source of carbohydrates
while pollen in the form of bee bread is
stored for utilization is a protein
source this here this yellow that's the
bee bread and here's the nectar that's
going to be either they'll lay an egg in
there somewhere or that's the neck sure
that's going to be dried into honey and
capped what's beautiful about that is it
doesn't matter what the vehicle for
communication is what matters is that 20
people have taken the time to on a
single theme annotate and carefully
described why these images matter to
them and to their research and that you
now can go and serve that information
I'll show one more issue of gigapan
magazine that way so we'll go back to
the magazine go to home and you can go
to prior issues like this we had one on
identity in locale we had one on cookout
Hawaii which was about Hawaii done by
our Hawaiian friends from the fine
foundation we had one on Brazil yes
environmental portraits and then this
prior one culture Shaw actually initiate
two more I guess so culture shop was
really neat the Gigot pans of shops in
various cultural places and this is one
of my favorites of course because I'm
Iranian or maybe this is in Japan this
is the Iranian one they have pictures in
Japan they have pictures in Iran but
it's beautiful because in fact I can go
in and read snapshots that described in
great detail how much of a nut culture
we are we are truly not for nuts in Iran
and we have really good nuts and I tell
you the detachments here tastes like
paper compared to our pistachios so I
don't know what's going on with the
sashes here the one I wanted to show you
is prior to this is the South Pole issue
it was guest edited by l'a derbyshire
are you
okay my guests are all missing
unfortunately he was here a second ago
like 5 literally 10 seconds ago but it's
a wonderful issue and i highly recommend
you go visit this because in this issue
you can learn all about fantastic
stories of the South Pole and so for
instance you can go and look at glow in
the dark absolutely stunning picture of
an Aurora you can full screen it zoom in
and see it in great detail and you can
have and and read detailed descriptions
of various constellations like Centaurus
and Terry's here's the moon this is
always fun the constellation virgo is
lost in the moonlight the moon behaves
strangely here rising for two weeks of
the crime and then disappearing below
the horizon for two weeks at a time
there's something I didn't know and I
thought I understood astrodynamics so
there's fantastic stories to read and i
highly recommend you keep a magazine but
more importantly i'm trying to sell on
you the idea of japan magazine is a
model for how you can curate and collect
and embody work that is deep but
spatially referenced okay i have some
fun things to share with you before i go
on because i forgot to do them at the
beginning one is just this morning
National Geographic came out with a news
article about our conference isn't that
cool and it's today's Daily News billion
pixel image tool probe science mysteries
they embedded active GigaPan inside the
national Geographics website for this so
there's an actual gigapan of the picture
that receives an award couple of nights
ago and it's there in National
Geographic and they put in pretty much
links to everybody who was displayed at
the exhibits so go to National
Geographic do a google news search on
national geographic and gigapan and
you'll get right into this which is
quite fantastic the other thing I want
to point out which is fun is that we
have a Giga panic here aureliano garden
and eze can you raise your hand
aureliano actually took a gigapan pro
shot if you'll recall while Dave
korsmeyer was talking and he sniffed it
and uploaded it so it's there and it's
we go to most recent is one of the the
recent ten or twenty GigaPan is uploaded
and it's great it's a fantastic shot you
can read the slides and you can see
probably a whole number of you and we
can see why I'm so happy because we're
getting this fantastic population two
people to all come here from all walks
of life
but full Oh God Oh in Google Earth you
put it in google earth excellent
excellent i'm not going to go there
right now because i'm running out of
time so those are some interesting site
side things to point out now let me go
tell you about the future of your
depends website and i know i have to
stop stuff this won't go along if we
want to support community there are
fundamental functionality that is i
think most important first steps we have
to take these are the things that were
just beta testing right now and will
soon release for you and ask me later
not tell you how soon one of them has to
do with the idea of categorization many
of you have taken to the tricks of using
tags to categorize but we want you to be
able to create both public and shared
categories of I'm sorry topic galleries
categorization means having a fixed
index of categories so that we can have
you labeling and semantically
understandable way as gig advance with
categories so that you're going to have
a diverse set of category names and tags
and a fixed set in categories we're
going to have both of those online which
is good what I'm talking about is
galleries we want you to be able to
collect your images together not that an
image belongs and only one gallery but
that you can have as many galleries as
you need to collect and prove and
demonstrate ideas in different ways and
so we have a gallery feature that we're
bringing out so that you can have
galleries and then share galleries with
people essentially like sharing a subset
of search results the other one is
groups which goes hand-in-hand with
galleries because after all you can ask
the question who should only gallery
maybe you want a private gallery of all
the two pictures you took in Honduras
but maybe what you want to do is have a
bird-watching group and then have the
bird-watching group have authority for
everybody in the group to add images
into the gallery and share them and
maybe you want the public to be able to
come and look at the images in the group
or maybe you want a private group where
you can have a really deep scientific
discussion you don't want anybody to
snapshot those particular pictures maybe
you want people to come and look at the
gallery look at the panoramas and see
your snapshots but you want only curated
snapshots so you don't want outside
people two randomly snapshot in there
because you're using it for teaching
it's a class and your snapshots are part
of the course work all of that you'll be
able to do with the new website and
that's exciting because it allows you to
organize your information
but also organize yourself in the locus
of the community so that you and your
friends or your students or your fellow
teachers can together organized images
and personality into groups that make
sense this is all important of course as
scale goes up right and you have 60,000
images or a hundred million images you
have to do something like this because
you can't surf it all there's no way to
run into the things you need so those
are some examples of the ways we're
going to be using semantic arrangements
of groups galleries and other kinds of
objects first class objects in the
GigaPan site very soon so that you can
do some more sophisticated ways of
organizing information and presenting it
so while you get that out because I
thought you'd enjoy that one of the
other features that people keep asking
us for and yes you're seeing asleep
snapshot of a beta site and I know I
shouldn't do that ever but one of the
other things people ask for is this kind
of control over their images a lot of
people say I love this but I really
don't want other people to snapshot it I
just want them to see it and so the new
stat the new website allows you to
decide do I want oh this is snapshot my
GigaPan do I want others to for this
particular give Japan being able to add
my GigaPan to their gallery or is it a
kind of a private gigapan look at it but
don't add it into a collection set do I
want others to comment on the gigapan
and of course there's more do I want
people to print my gay japan do I want
them to download it in a certain level
of resolution if I allow others to print
it how much do I want in royalty return
if they print my gigapan so all of those
were addressing in this next version I
have one final story to tell and then
I'll stop because I'm going to time
myself out not having an introducer
means I can run over but i won't i
promise it's one final story is one of
the really early stories we had and it
has to do with the place called san
francisco el alto but again it
demonstrates the power of what where we
think we're headed and why we think this
is important so i'm going to go to
Microsoft PowerPoint and I mean Google
and just show you how to get there
yourself it's san francisco el alto and
existing you get pan and by the way
those are you haven't forget this out
type in stuff into google with the word
GigaPan and you get yoga pants it's a
fabulous way of indexing searching into
our site so that works really well so
there's the top hit go into it and the
reason I'm showing you this gigapan is
because early on one of the
one of the first 20 gigatons we've ever
made with the unit that was made of
pieces of aluminum and wires hanging out
this was done here in Guatemala and what
was exciting about the picture was I
didn't know how to interpret this
picture and so there's a local macarthur
foundation fellow named luis von ahn who
is from Guatemala and so Luis sat down
with us and talked us through the
picture he gave us a tour I want to give
you a bit of that flavor because what he
did was so exciting I'm not going to
even look at the snapshots I'm just
going to go straight to full screen to
show you what I'm interested in showing
you so let me go to full screen and what
he did was he said you know first of all
something exciting about this is it's
the largest open-air market in Central
America of course I didn't know that
next thing that he did was he said
there's a aspect seeing people the way
they're behaving the clothing they're
wearing and learning about the culture
here you see somebody on the Left
carrying something on their head without
holding with their hands well it turns
out in Guatemala it's an easy way to
determine whether somebody has a large
lineage in bottom Allah or whether they
are from a colonial side and many many
people will do this balancing thing a
whole other set of people with a
different culture identity will not and
so you can really tell people and tell
their cultures apart that way another
one is this rope on the forehead I
thought that was fascinating I've never
done that anybody know what that's for
so here's what Louise told us that this
is the hands-free way of carrying heavy
things you put the rope across your head
and you carry big heavy things like VCR
or a small television or something
around by hanging it and then you hand
is still free I didn't know that I never
would have occurred to me and of course
then I had to go and see are there big
things like televisions in the open air
market oh yeah there are televisions
right there look cool one final story
for you one of the things that's really
beautiful to see in a picture like this
and I know it's easy to take pictures of
static places with any kind of gigapixel
imaging technology because things aren't
moving so it's easy but it's worth the
trouble when you have humans because you
see humanity and I don't care how many
mistakes there are as you can see the
mistakes don't get in the way of us
having a deep exploration that's
wonderful but there's color and there's
also the kind of material these
ropes I just found gorgeous and then
after visiting the ropes I went up and I
hope I don't make you seasick through
all this I went up and looked a little
bit at the cloth and asked group ask
Lewis about that is kind of interesting
ok so this cloth they're lying against
the wall what's up with that we will
just buy bolts of cloth will take it
home he said take it home no no they buy
bolts of cloth may take the clothes home
what I mean is well you just go to the
left just walk down the aisle what do
you mean well you buy the cloth then you
walk over here to the left you go in
front of the clothing stands here these
are cloth people have already tailored
into something you walk past those check
out if there's something you like you
keep going I hope I don't get lost
because if I get lost I'll have to ask
for directions ok I'm nearly lost have I
lost my way no maybe not and you go here
to the sewing machines and you tell
people what you want and then make it
for you and then you take it home what a
cool story not a story that I would have
ever been able to jigsaw puzzle together
by myself but when told by Louise it
allows me to see the image with a
completely different light anyway that's
a great story because it's there and you
can share with students and peers and
just search for san francisco el alto so
i think the take-home message is that
you understand our goals with the
GigaPan site we're always going to be
interested in understanding what your
needs are that further what you will
understand or is our common ground in
our common goals it is becoming very
challenging to even keep up with the
data because it's so steep so ninety
percent of our effort is in simply
maintaining usability of the site given
how big the data is getting and yet it's
our onus to introduce the kinds of
features that make it the best possible
community site it can be and for that
we're all those ears and riesling to you
and hoping that you can give us the
magic potions that allow us to go and
make great progress x it's and it is 1
30 so it's time for the next session so
thank you for the attention